votre ville a des bureaux ce monsieur
fernandel deux oscars parmi d'autres le
dernier en date est de l'italie où
précisément
oui mais l'italie avant que j'avais
arrête le film fait huer un bureau
nascar sept jours à part exactement
exactement cellulaire avant que vous
arrêtiez ce film qui a pour nom don
camillo et c'est pour tester ses
cantates et aussi parce que on la
pensait que si on mettait donc améliorer
les contestataires ça touchait toute la
jeunesse d'un disque et ses
contestataires c'est ce qui compte est
donc à venir naturellement dans ce film
c'est le dernier de la série d'ailleurs
je sais qu'on va dire c'est pas vrai
pour ce qu'on dit toujours le dernier
comme les adieux mais y en aura plus tôt
avec le voir est ce qui m
alors forcément c'est le dernier livre
qu'il avait écrits qui s'appelait don
camillo et les jeunes et là on a fait
nos moutons camille au ces
contestataires
c'est exactement la même chose c'est à
dire que dans ce film le fils de peppone
lui et tom maoïste et le nièce à moi que
je ne connais pas mais que j'ai quand
même et hippie sourit ce que ça donne
déjà alors en plus de paix punk et
communistes et moi qui suis ce que je
suis sacré beaucoup d'histoires mais des
histoires différentes de celles que nous
avons vues
ce ne sera pas uniquement le
conventionnel de jésus-christ don
camillo et peppone cette fois ya les
jeunes john's rouspète et les hippies
sommes pas d'accord avec les maoïstes
les communistes pas du tout d'accord
avec le 2 et moi avec personne voire
assiste actuellement leur match
n'accepte pas non plus le concile
commandes on me doit un quad gieter on
m'envoie parce que je veux pas dire la
messe de face je veux continuer comme
avant la déroute de dos cela je veux on
veut me prendre le christ je ne veux pas
alors je vais trouver les communistes
guillaume pêche que le christ soit prise
parce que c'est là qu'ils ont été
baptisés avec ce christ ils ont
redémarré alors ça fait toute une
histoire tout à fait différente de celle
qu en huit ans
à mon avis j'ai tourné 14 jours j'ai vu
35e minute de film bon n'est ce pas jean
lapointe cinq minutes et christian jacq
l'a fait un travail remarquable et je
crois que c'est le plus drôle d'insérer
don camillo dispensant d'occupation si
on peut lire les personnages derrière
mon personnage le cinéma pour vous dans
l'avenir les années qui viennent c'est
quoi et comment
pour l'instant je ne peux pas vous
répondre étant donné que je ne sais pas
si le cinéma suivant l'évolution du
cinéma car vous savez depuis quelques
années la tellement évolué bien on
arrive à plus comprendre certaines
choses
c'est pour ça que je suis resté assez
éloigné de la caméra depuis depuis
longtemps mais à mon âge maintenant je
crois que si je fais d'autres films
après donc a mis en garde ses jamais ce
que tu reviennes le temps qu'a mis un
nom dernier si je fais d'autres films je
crois que ça sera des films qui
marqueront parce que je ne ferais que
des films ou un personnage non pas faire
une copié en parlant bouton camille en
fonction des gens de ces films là ma
faim il fallait trouver comme un
personnage comme gabin d'ailleurs nous
sommes des gens à un personnage
comprenez et je crois que malgré tout le
plus vite maintenant à l'air de revenir
au film à histoire est un peu lassé des
films morbide des films sexy et des
films de faux intellectuel c'est à dire
le film où on sort en disant c'est
formidable et on n'a rien compris mais
ça y paraît que ça serait beaucoup alors
ça m'est arrivé amoureuse et moi je
disais pas c'est formidable en sortant
mais les gens le disaient n'est ce pas
parlez nous de prouver que puis-je vous
dire de bourvil j'ai perdu une dent
camara 9e
nous avons perdu parce que le public a
été vraiment touchée c'était un acteur
populaire
il méritait cette popularité puis moi
qu'il ait connu puisque j'étais sonné je
l' ai connu à ses débuts et dès que je
les ai vus la première fois j'ai pensé
qu'il deviendrait quelqu'un parce que il
avait en plus de son commis que nature
et c'est en déclin bon ville était une
nature il avait aussi ce charme
et cette humanité dégage un acteur vrai
nous avons fait ensemble un fils zach la
cuisine au beurre qui n'était pas un
film émouvant mais qui était un film
très drôle mais c'est là j'ai pu
apprécier par là ces deux mois de
tournage c'était la bonté même la
gentillesse personnifie et c'était le
type qui aimait tout le monde était bien
avec tout le monde
les [ __ ] est le petit choc émotionnel qui
a poussé bruit lors de sa province et ce
alors monde il a été un spectacle animé
par un cercle infernal mais c'est un
fait que dans les spectacles de
pourville est toujours un spectateur ne
me faire non plus oui je vous dirai
pourquoi parce que je n'en ai pas parlé
par modestie parce que bon rythme mais
parlez lui même il avait commencé sa
carrière
selon andré raimbourg d'ailleurs son
vrai nom s'interdit dia s'il avait eu un
premier prix à un crochet et puis moi
lorsqu'il a commencé à débuter à paris
et que je les ai vus sans le connaître
je suis allé un jour le voir à la paix
c'est sa première fois qu'ils me brière
était tout étonné de me voir en train sa
loge c'est elle et pour le féliciter
pourrait dire je vous suis beaucoup
essayé avec ma famille le suivi un peu
dans tout les opératrices jouer c'est
bien pour nous avons subi dans les films
qu'il a fait bien entendu mais je
reconnais que bon ville me faisait rire
ou contrôler et dans l'intérieur est un
acteur comique je suis un bon public
il n'y a pas beaucoup d'acteurs qui
m'ont fait rire non pas par manque de
talent mais à fuir vers certaines
actuelle vous savez qu'il ne vous touche
pas au point de vue comique
est-ce que bourvil ab en rire un petit
peu extraordinaire à en rire comme vous
diriez moi j'avais autre chose mais
bourvil avait en rire il a bien rire une
manière de parler ce qu'il donnait cette
personnalité puis avec cette
personnalité franchement comique
il est arrivé être un acteur un acteur
important
la traversée de paris là pour épicier le
grand prix à venise puis après il a fait
les ventes de dell ou été très bien nous
avons fait un tout seul en plus la
cuisine au beurre après tout ça et bien
croyez moi pour ville
sera difficilement remplaçable dans le
cinéma français
car il ne manque pas de talent il en
sortira certainement de nouveau le
cinéma français a perdu un acteur
irremplaçable et moi j'ai perdu un grand
m d'une manière générale ne veut pas que
mélancolique quelquefois justement
constatant que les choses et les gens
passent mélancolique non parce que l'on
attendrait le long comic je sais mais
non je suis un acteur optimiste mais
naturellement que j'ai vu notre métier a
eu une espagne mauvaise passe puisque ça
coince et par luis mariano puis après ça
a été le jeune théo sarapo puis ça a été
jacques pis ça a été bernard noël
et puis c'était beau fils naturellement
que tout ça on peut être mélancolique
après ça dans notre métier où ses quatre
métiers tous les grandes familles et
lorsque l'on peut un camarade même que
l'on ne connaît pas il semble qu'on a
connus comme un ami d'école laup rooney
et je dois dire que dans tous ceux qui
ont disparu lice marianne aurait été un
très gentil garçon que je connaissais
aussi tôt disparu très jeune comme
bourvil et bruit m'a touché comme si
vraiment j'avais perdu quelqu'un un être
cher car comme j'ai et irremplaçable et
puis ce sont des gens qui vous laissent
quelque chose vous prenez il laissera je
crois dans le cinéma français dans 20 ou
30 ans 10 6 ans dira il y avait un
comique qui s'appelait pour ville